Ha habido quien nos ha preguntado por qué afirmamos que Donald Trump no es un hombre
"pro-negocio" si al fin y al cabo lo que
defiende es bajar fuertemente los
impuestos, especialmente aquéllos que
afectan más directamente a las empresas
pues bien hoy vamos a tratar de
sumergirnos un poquito más en el
programa de Donald Trump y en sus ideas
para dejar claro por qué su elección
sería una catástrofe para las empresas
y la economía norteamericana
Soy Enrique Couto y esto es VisualPolitik
Donald Trump se presenta como un hombre de
negocios. Sin embargo, paradójicamente su
elección supondría toda una catástrofe
para las empresas americanas
Hoy vamos a tratar de justificar esa tesis con tres puntos principales: el primero de
ellos, los impuestos.
Es verdad que el señor Trump propone una
bajada de impuestos muy elevada
de hecho hay quienes cuantifican esta
bajada en impuestos en aproximadamente
un billón de dólares americanos
Es decir dos veces todo el dinero que
recaudan los diferentes gobiernos que hay
en España dos veces todo el dinero que recaudan
los ayuntamientos, las diputaciones las
autonomías y el Estado central
Sin embargo los impuestos no lo son
todo, es verdad que unos impuestos moderados
ayudan a las empresas y a la actividad
económica pero para favorecer la
inversión y el crecimiento se requieren
instituciones creíbles, una política
macroeconómica prudente, una política
de atracción de inversiones, una normativa que
proteja la propiedad privada, entre otros muchos factores. En definitiva, instituciones fuertes.
Eso es lo que hace, por ejemplo, que Dinamarca
sea mucho más rico que Armenia y que
además sea más fácil hacer negocios
en Dinamarca que en Armenia, aún cuando
en el segundo país los impuestos son
más bajos que en Dinamarca.
Además el señor Donald Trump nos habla de cuánto va a bajar los impuestos pero no nos dice
nada del gasto. Estados Unidos tiene un déficit de aproximadamente 450 mil
millones de dólares. Esto es un déficit equivalente a todos los impuestos que se recaudan en España.
Pero el señor Trump dice que no va
a bajar el gasto público, por tanto una de dos:
o nos están mintiendo o es un inepto.
Lo cierto es que para que exista una
política macroeconómica prudente y sea
creíble para los inversores y para las
empresas esta tiene que ser seria,
predecible y rigurosa, y el señor Trump
no nos habla nada de esto.
El segundo punto es la visión que el señor Donald Trump tiene sobre la globalización y el libre
comercio
El señor Trump es un nacionalista que dice querer defender a la industria
norteamericana de la competencia
exterior.
Y lo quiere hacer por la fuerza, mediante decretazo,  estableciendo aranceles a las importaciones y lo cierto es que
esto ni es una política nueva ni
nunca ha tenido mucho éxito. Ya se aplicó en
el pasado en EE.UU. y las
consecuencias fueron terroríficas.
En 1929, otro republicano populista que
había ganado las elecciones también
prometiendo proteccionismo, H. Hoover, comenzó a imponer los primeros
aranceles a los productos agroalimentarios
Y a eso le siguió en 1930 una gran ley
para establecer aranceles para
prácticamente proteger a toda la
industria norteamericana
Claro, otros países reaccionaron de la
misma forma estableciendo también sus propios
aranceles y lo que se generó fue un gran
caos mundial: el comercio internacional se
desplomó
De hecho las ventas de Estados Unidos a
Europa cayeron más de un 50% y con
eso se determinó la especialización
productiva de cada país.
¿Qué ocurrió? Pues que proyectos empresariales
quebraron, muchas fábricas cerraron y
millones de obreros estadounidenses
perdieron su trabajo
Ese fue resultado de las políticas que hoy
defiende Donald Trump.
La realidad es que las consecuencias serían aún peores
porque hoy la producción global está
mucho más interconectada, por ejemplo
los productos que consumimos en el día a día,
lo habitual es que haya sido
producido en muchos países diferentes
Por ejemplo, en la industria automovilística, una las
denuncias que hace el señor Donald Trump
es que las grandes compañías de coches
norteamericanas se han implantado sus fábricas
de ensamblaje en México, pero lo que olvida
es que el 40% de los componentes de cada
coche que México vende a Estados Unidos
ha sido fabricado previamente por
obreros norteamericanos.
Es decir, si como
quiere el señor Donald Trump se fijasen aranceles y
se impidiese este reparto que favorece
la especialización productiva lo que nos
encontraríamos es con una menor
competitividad de la industria
norteamericana y con un menor poder adquisitivo de los consumidores norteamericanos
En definitiva mal: para todos.
En tercer lugar tenemos la obsesión del
señor Donald Trump con la inmigración
Y es que, como comentamos en vídeos precedentes, el señor Trump quiere deportar a más de
11 millones de personas
Y claro, esto tendría consecuencias, en
primer lugar consecuencias en términos
de coste y competitividad para
muchísimas industrias de bajo valor
añadido que lo pasarían realmente mal.
Por ejemplo, ¿quién iba a recoger la
fresa en California, su hija?
Y en segundo lugar, consecuencias
en términos de demanda porque no
podemos obviar estas once millones de
personas consumen y ahorran en los
EE.UU., pero es que además la
inmigración tiene también elementos de
adición de valor que son esenciales
para toda economía. Siguiendo al
profesor Hausmann y la Teoría Scrabble
del Desarrollo, podemos decir que los
productos se forman con letras que las
letras son las capacidades productivas de
cada persona y que cuantas más letras
tengamos, más palabras complejas podemos fabricar.
Es decir, los inmigrantes han
tenido experiencias distintas y por
eso tienen unos ratios de emprendimiento
más elevados, suelen potenciar el
comercio con sus países de origen y
además, qué diantres, impulsan la
creatividad y la innovación
Yahoo, Google o Amazon fueron puestas en
marcha, en gran medida, por inmigrantes.
Por todo ello: por impuestos, libre
comercio, e inmigración decimos que
el señor Donald Trump es un terror para
las empresas norteamericanas.